I remember the day my husband Rudy
called me on the phone and said get rid
of our TV sell it donate it do whatever
you want with it I've already gotten rid
of our video game console
my jaw dropped I could not believe what
I had just heard this was a man that at
any free time he had would be found to
glued to the screen I would often get
home from work after a 12 hour shift at
the hospital to be greeted while he
remained in his seat and only turned his
head but maintained his eyes on the
screen the entire time
I often ate dinner alone I went to bed
alone and even though I was a newlywed I
often felt lonely and looking back this
one decision this one habit change not
only dramatically improved our marriage
but it completely changed our lives for
the better hey friends it's yesi I
originally intended for this channel to
be about minimalism and decluttering but
somewhere along the lines I realized
that minimalism is truly a lifestyle
that allows you to live life more fully
with less and that it is about so much
more than just reading yourself of
physical possessions and items but it
can also span into improving your
relationships your finances and your
relationship with technology which is
what we will talk about today I've
previously shared with you the six
reasons why we no longer own a TV and
what originally prompted that decision
today I'm going to share with you some
of the ways that it has changed our
lives but first I just want to clarify
that this in no way is meant as a
judgment to you if you own or choose to
watch television I used to love binge
watching the home renovations or the
Hallmark Christmas movies on a cold
December day but as you can see we did
not have balance it was very much a
negative habit for us and often the
easiest way or the quickest way to cut
out a negative habit is to eliminate the
trigger altogether which is what we
chose to do also by then we had both
already deleted our social media
accounts which I talk about more in my
digital minimalism playlist and I'll
link that at the end of this video in
case you want to hear more about that
but if you have any special tips of your
own on how you have a better balance
with your television maybe meet
somewhere in the middle please share in
the comments down below because maybe
completely getting rid of it all
together may not be the key for everyone
foreign
first and foremost dramatically improved
our marriage Rudy and I were both broken
in our own ways I had horrible shopping
habits which I share about in another
video and he had an addiction to the
television screen specifically video
games and because of that I became very
resentful very jealous of this screen
this object that robbed me of the time
with the man that I love and he now
tells me that he often wouldn't even
realize how long he spent on the screen
because to him it just felt like just a
little bit longer Just One More Level
just one more episode and before we knew
it it had become well after midnight
when we get up at 4 30 to 5 in the
morning only to do the whole thing all
over again and the most immediate change
that I can tell happened right away is
that it made us come face to face with
our addictions
our daughter Anna was on the way and it
led us to ask questions
what do we want out of life what are our
priorities
and how do our daily actions reflect
that
we had to intentionally Define our
values and set our priorities straight
so that the life that we live is a
reflection of what we value the most
television and social media usage are at
all-time highs
sadly anxiety depression and loneliness
only seem to be worsening with time
there's a thing called the negativity
bias which is our tendency to become
more affected by the negative
experiences that we have rather than the
positive ones so when we watch the news
and we watch horrible things happening
around the world it shapes our
perspective of the world this constant
receiving of negative information about
how humans treat each other and treat
the world is often what leads people to
believe that there is no more good in
the world trust no one and if things can
go wrong they will go wrong and so on
but when you intentionally surround
yourself with positive people and
nurture friendships that motivate you to
be a better person and also cut off
these negative news feeds what are you
left with positivity so while the rest
of the world may be focused on how
horrible the recession is going to be or
that the zombie apocalypse is coming you
instead are out having coffee with a
friend that motivates you to work on
that project you've been meaning to work
on instead of focusing on the things
that you cannot change
and of course cutting out that cable
bill saved us money every month some
cable companies will charge around sixty
dollars a month or even more for special
plans so in the course of a year after
five years that's three thousand six
hundred dollars but putting the cable
bill aside I was able to make huge
improvements on my horrible shopping
habits because of having gotten rid of
the TV because since I didn't have
television and also I didn't have social
media at that time including this
YouTube channel it meant that I wasn't
constantly bombarded with commercials
and infomercials telling me all the
things that I needed that I was missing
out on and that awesome Robot vacuum
that was going to fix all my problems
this change made the difficult challenge
of curing my shopping addiction much
easier because I now wasn't constantly
bombarded with messages telling me that
I needed more so it became easier to
shift my focus towards a feeling of
abundance
advertisers often create a feeling of
lack in us so because I see this
commercial about this awesome Robot
vacuum now all of a sudden this room
that I have that I was perfectly content
with is no longer enough now I went from
a state of being perfectly content to
feeling like I'm missing out on
something like I need something more and
what I have isn't good enough and this
constant falling into this feeling of I
need I need I need really just trains
our mind to feeling scarcity and when I
no longer had social media or television
to tell me all the things that I didn't
have that other people did or in my
husband's case all the video games that
he was missing out on now we could focus
our energy and our minds towards a
feeling of abundance and contentment
foreign
not only removes so much negativity but
it also freed up lots of time we
reconnected with old Hobbies we also
found that we were a lot more creative
because of this so now instead of
consuming content we were looking for
new hobbies to adopt or things that we
could create and instead of hitting them
all because I was bored I worked out I
found new hobbies such as painting and I
picked up reading again Rudy also had
time for what he loves which is
Woodworking and building furniture and
we often spent more time together as a
family by doing things that we both love
such as hiking and it eventually led me
to creating this YouTube channel where I
hope that through sharing my story it
will be encouraging to you not to avoid
all forms of technology altogether but
to find the best balance that works for
you that allows you to live with an
abundant mindset
the domino effect in reference to our
habits refers to a phenomenon that
occurs all the time when we change one
habit it often leads to a Cascade of
other effects because of it like a
ripple effect when a stone hits the
water so to give you a personal example
that I had made a mistake with is that I
had binged watched television through
the night I got up late that morning to
go to work and so because of that I was
in a rush I grabbed a coffee because I
didn't have time for breakfast so I'm
rushing through traffic someone pulls
out in front of me because I'm in a rush
and I jam on the brakes to spill coffee
all over myself so that it looks like I
peed on myself and now my car is full of
coffee everywhere so you can guess how
the next parts of my day went did not go
very well for me I was late to work so
work piled up it was stressful I had to
explain to everybody I didn't pee myself
it was coffee I assure you it was coffee
you know and sometimes this happens when
we make one change it leads to us all
sorts of other changes this this was a
pretty crummy day for me but the awesome
thing is that it also works the other
way around when you adopt positive
habits it leads to a Cascade of other
changes because of it I find that we
often think of Transforming Our Lives as
these big huge changes that we have to
make but it's often those little changes
those small habits that we do every day
that build together create dramatic
long-lasting results Rudy and I
eliminated a trigger that was leading us
into a negative Direction and because of
that it led to us adopting positive
habits and I still feel the Chain
Reaction occurring I hope that in
sharing my story it's giving you
something positive to think about and
please share your thoughts and your
suggestions down in the comments below
I'd love to hear from you if you like
this video please don't forget to give
it a thumbs up subscribe or share it
with a friend so that it can help more
people and to all my subscribers thank
you so so so much for your support it
really means a lot to me thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you in
the next one bye for now
[Music]